breaking news ted cruz is trying to
repeal some of the language in the
infrastructure bill that specifically
goes after the crypto industry this is a
big big deal now we've got this overview
here that says that texas senator ted
cruz is seeking to strip language
defining who a crypto broker is from the
multi-billion dollar infrastructure
package according to a recent statement
from his office this new legislation
this proposal if it's passed would
remove language aimed at tightening
reporting requirements for brokers in
the digital asset space this legislation
that he's putting forward mirrors an
earlier attempt by crews and other
politicians to eliminate the language
from the infrastructure package now the
point here is that ultimately there was
a ton of effort there was literally
tweets and tweets and tweets there was
all these phone calls emails etc to
politicians both in the senate and
congress trying to raise this issue
before the infrastructure bill went to
president joe biden's office but
ultimately it did not get changed biden
got the infrastructure bill in its
current form and he signed it into law
on monday now supporters of the
definitions have said that the expanded
definition would help provide funding
for the infrastructure package so what
they essentially are doing is they're
trying to broaden the definition of a
broker so that there's more reporting
requirements on those brokers that more
reporting would allow the irs to go and
get more tax revenue the problem is that
in many cases those brokers things that
fall under the terminology broker can't
actually do it in some cases what this
law would require is that if you are
participating in a transaction whether
you are their sender the receiver or
deemed a facilitator or a broker you
have to have the participants name their
social security number and other
information about them but what happens
if for example a miner they are
processing transactions to some degree
they're securing the network they have
no clue who is sending what to who all
they know is that they are there to
validate blocks they are there to secure
the network and so ultimately there is a
problem a lot of this law is not going
to actually be able to be applied and so
we have a quote from cruz himself he
says as a deliberative body the senate
should have done its job and held
hearings to properly understand the
consequences of legislating on this
emerging industry before we risk the
livelihoods and privacy of participating
americans i urge my colleagues in the
senate to repeal this harmful language
that will create regulatory uncertainty
and in turn an unnecessary barrier to
innovation now that is the key here is
that if the united states wants to be a
leader in this industry we cannot have
legislation that ends up causing
friction we can't have legislation that
ends up offshoring a lot of that
innovation we want to be the leader we
want anyone in the world no matter who
you are where you come from what your
wealth status is your education level
who your parents are or what country or
language you are coming from or you
speak we want you to come to the united
states and help build this industry this
industry has economic prosperity tied to
it job creation and ultimately it is
technology and innovation if we want to
be a technology leader in the 21st
century we have to be a leader in
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and so
ultimately what we are watching occur
here is we are watching a bill that got
pushed forward that bill had nothing to
do with the crypto industry it was all
about infrastructure and spending and
they needed to find a way to be able to
pay for it and so naturally they went
and looked at a fast-growing industry
like crypto and they were able to put
this language in there that said oh we
should expand what the definition of a
broker is and therefore they will have
to
participate in more reporting for the
irs that sounds innocent but when you
start to look at the fact that it can't
be applied in many cases ted cruz and
other politicians like senator alumnus
in wyoming and many others are now
trying to get this fixed the only way to
do it now that the bill has been signed
into law is to put forward new
legislation to repeal specific parts of
the language so it'll be interesting to
see are they able to actually get this
legislative language repealed or will we
see what their ability to enforce this
new language becomes either way though
politicians are waking up bitcoin and
crypto in the industry this is the
future of america there's no other
technology in the world that is more
american than bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and it's great to see
these politicians leaning in and trying
to protect a fast-growing small industry
that will represent trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars of
economic opportunity over the coming
decade